hi i'm tina fey and i play 22 in disney
and pixar's soul
what's up guys i'm quest love i play
curly hi
i am felicia rashad and i play liver
hi i'm jamie foxx and i play joe gardner
in disney and pixar's soul
hi i'm angela bassett and i play
dorothea williams i'm here with buzzfeed
to take the which pixar heroes are you a
combination of quiz
here we go
first how would your bff
describe you witty loving
honest reliable bold genuine
or african-american i'm kidding it
actually doesn't say that
okay i think i'm gonna say reliable
actually because
even though i'm a comedy person you
would think it would pick witty but
everybody i know is witty so that
wouldn't be
a distinguishing feature i'm gonna say
reliable my name is questlove so i might
as well be loving right
reliable witty i will say
reliable i am reliable you can count on
me pick a sidekick for my next adventure
rex from toy story emma lynch from a
bug's life
remy from ratsutooli doug from up
squared from finding nemo
or bing bong from inside out i have a
fear of rats
in general especially rats in the
kitchen i think i'm gonna pick doug
from up i guess i'm kind of a dog person
in denial
i'm picking squirt as my sidekick for my
next adventure because
squirt is a fish and is in the water and
i like that
well remy really made an impression on
me
remy likes to travel i love to travel i
love to be nurtured
with food and friends and good wine so
we'll have a
great great time i would have to go with
doug
from up bing bong from inside out
because
i love richard kind and i love inside
out choose your favorite part
of a movie a unique storyline an
unforgettable
soundtrack fun characters a fantastic
setting cool costume designs the
acting duh i am going to go with the
acting because it's about the actors it
relates more
to the actors when they are doing their
acting they are
more about their acting as they say it
starts with the words on the page
so yes i would say a unique storyline i
think i'm going to say
fun characters that's what i like to
write lots of different characters and
it's also what i like to watch
i have to say i liked the storyline
music means everything to me so of
course i'm going to choose an
unforgettable soundtrack
pick a random talent eyebrow dancing
writing with your toes juggling folding
your tongue
fitting marshmallows in your mouth
whistling
like a bird i don't have any of these
but if there was one that i think i
would be interested in developing
eyebrow dancing ever since i started the
tonight show
steve higgins is the master bird person
steve higgins our announcer and
um so he's taught me how to whistle like
a bird so i'm gonna
choose whistling like a bird
i would pick folding your tongue here i
go
i'm gonna say fitting marshmallows in
your mouth because
it's just making me think about
marshmallows and now i wish i had
toasted marshmallows
folding your tongue pick a disney
classic the little mermaid
lion king beauty and the beast aladdin
mulan or pocahontas i'm gonna say mulan
it's got
solid story energy i'm gonna have to
choose
the one disney film that i saw
[Laughter]
i don't have kids yet i saw the lion
king so i picked the lion king
i would say lion king let's go back to
wakanda or wakanda next door
mulan is my choice the girl
was fierce i am going to go with
the lion king sky scar
pick a soulful song for karaoke my girl
the temptations
respect me baby could never spell that i
feel good hey james brown let's play
together
al green what's going on marvin gaye
reasons earth wind and fire
i'm gonna say let's play together
i don't think amateur singers should
attempt respect
so i'm not going to say respect i think
i'll go with let's stay together
because i feel like it's possibly more
singable and i like the message
that's an impossible choice but let's
say for right now
because of you know it was a turn for
him in his life he really
said something just deep about what's
going on
in society what's going on marvin gaye
i'm going to pick reasons by earth wind
fire only because there's a funny story
of how this couple offered the millions
of dollars
to sing reasons at a wedding out of
guilt the lead singer of that song
philip bailey told the couple
reasons is about an affair so we don't
know if you want this
at your wedding and sure enough
earthworm fire lost millions of dollars
i'm gonna pick miss aretha franklin's
respect
and i'll let you guess why finally pick
a disney quote to live by
i never look back darling it distracts
from the now adventure is out there
when life gets you down do you want to
know what you've got to do
just keep swimming venture outside your
comfort zone
the rewards are worth it we can't focus
on what's going wrong there's always a
way to turn things around
the rest of the world may follow the
rules but i must follow my heart
i will choose the last one the rest of
the world may follow the rules but i
will
follow my heart i'm a guy that always
goes outside my comfort
zone so let's venture outside of it i'm
gonna say
the dory quote when life gets you down
do you want to know what you've got to
do
just keep swimming adventure is out
there
i love to travel i love to meet new
people see new things
so that works for me i'm going to choose
the first one
i never look back darling it distracts
from the view
[Music]
oh wow i'm part joy in part wali my
girlfriend will be very pleased that i'm
joy joy
and wally like joy you're naturally
happy person who prefers to look at life
with an optimistic view and like wali
i'm super inquisitive and i have
eagerness and a love for learning
very spot-on buzzfeed i will take that
i'd agree with that
i am a combination of miguel and flick
like miguel you're super family oriented
and would go above and beyond for those
you love
and like flick you're an intuitive soul
what who's always willing to lend a
helping hand excellent that is gonna
make
amazing and confusing halloween costume
for me next year
you got russell and nemo like russell
you're a ball of energy with a natural
sense
of curiosity and like nemo you don't get
discouraged by obstacles thrown your way
i feel like that's my thing you're a
combination of woody and elastigirl like
woody you are extremely loyal to your
friends
they know they can always depend on you
to lend a listening ear
and like elastigirl you're a true
fighter when it comes to achieving your
dreams
i accept all right buzzfeed thank you
for the awesome quiz
go check out seoul on disney plus
december 25th
on christmas can't wait i promise you'll
love it
you